[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de
ce un magazine rugby à l'union rugby
centre 78 s'est largement imposé ce
week-end contre melun combs senart dans
un match à sens unique
le résultat à 42 à 0 le résumé de la
rencontre dans ce magazine rugby encore
les finale interacadémique de rugby
féminin était organisée ce mercredi au
stade robert barran de plaisir cet
événement en groupe et 70 joueuses de 15
à 17 ans retour sur cet événement dans
ce set 8 sport cyclisme le paris-nice
s'élancera ce dimanche depuis à plaisir
pour la première fois de son histoire le
lendemain le peloton partira depuis
chambreuse nous parlerons de cette
course au soleil avec nos invités
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres un
mot de football le tirage au sort pour
les demi-finales de la coupe des
yvelines s'est tenu la semaine dernière
coignières qui a sorti le tenant du
titre aura un nouveau gros morceau sur
son chemin avec mon repas l'une des
meilleures équipes de d1 district dans
l'autre rencontre bailly noisy recevra
hardricourt et rencontres sont
programmées le 5 avril prochain à partir
de 15 heures
on continue par le championnat de
nationale 3 verset s'est une nouvelle
fois brillamment imposé les versailles
ont dominé boulogne billancourt sur le
score de trois buts à zéro victoire qui
permet aux joueurs de la cité royale de
conserver la première place du
classement devant ivry avec un bilan de
12 victoires en 17 matches joués
quelques étages plus bas en régionale 2
trappes n'a pas joué ce week-end contre
champigny la rencontre a été déplacée à
une date ultérieure suite aux
intempéries de ce week end au classement
trappe reste donc avant dernier après 13
journées à disputer en d1 deux districts
seulement deux matchs et eto o et
étaient au programme ce week-end toutes
les autres rencontres ont été reportées
un vrai cours s'est imposé 7-1 contre le
pec autre match à sens unique celui de
maurepas contre bois d'arcy le score 7 à
0 les deux équipes que l'on retrouvera
en demi finale de coupe des îles in
occupent les deux premières places du
classement
maurepas et premiers airs des cours
deuxièmement on continue à part du rugby
un beau week-end pour l'union rugby
centre 78e le club né d'une fusion entre
le ska et rugby et montigny le
bretonneux en septembre s'est largement
imposé contre le rugby melun combs
senart le score 42 à 0 le résumé du
match
avantage de sang une fontaine la tempête
n'a pas arrêté lui versé 78 à montigny
le bretonneux ce dimanche 1er mars
l'union rugby centre 78 est parvenu à
jouer avec les éléments pour s'imposer
dans un match à sens unique contre melun
combs senart ce camp final 42 à 0 avec
six essais à la clé l'équipe se relance
après sept matches sans victoire
extraordinaire
on a retrouvé enfin l'importance qu'on a
retrouvé la victoire ça vous n'avez pas
gagné et on va dire que les conditions
nous obliger à nous resserrer à jouer de
manière plus solidaire et c'est pas plus
c'était peut-être pas mal pour un bien
mais on va s'en souvenir de ce match om
parce que les conditions étaient assez
incroyable des conditions de jeu inédite
qui ont fait de la casse chez les
adversaires les visiteurs ont dû
déclarer forfait avant la fin du match
après plusieurs blessures
il ya eu plein de problèmes mais l
arbitre qui a eu un problème également
et ensuite l'équipe adverse qui était
pas suffisant tard et on la met sur le
score était déjà fait en soi donc ça ne
change pas grand-chose à la logique du
match au classement le rc 78 toujours
septièmes du championnat et désormais
six victoires engrangées depuis le début
de la saison
prochain match dans cette division
honneur le 8 mars prochain sur le
terrain de paris quelques étages plus
haut en fédérale 2 l'équivalent de la 4e
division française plaisir à réaliser un
petit exploit en s'imposant à domicile
contre sarcelles le score 25 à 12 cette
victoire permet aux plaisirs wa de
remonter au classement dernier à début
janvier les joueurs de sébastien
roncalli se retrouve 9e sur 12
des résultats qui pourraient leur
permettre de finir la saison en milieu
de classement en fédérale 3 à grosse
déconvenue pour versailles excellent
depuis le début de la saison les versets
ils se sont lourdement inclinés dans le
derby yvelinois face à houilles
carrières sur seine
le score est sans appel 66 à 0 un match
sans qui a des conséquences au
classement les joueurs de la cité royale
redescendre à la quatrième place mais
ils sont toujours en course pour une
qualification en fin de saison du rugby
féminin à présent les finale
interacadémique se sont déroulées à ce
mercredi sur le terrain de plaisir cinq
équipes se sont affrontées parmi elles
les lycéennes du lycée plaisir wa de
jean vilar
c'était une grande première ambiance
avec aurélie rond et marie-hélène yapi
chine
[Applaudissements]
elles ont entre 15 et 17 ans et sont 10
à défendre les couleurs de lycée jean
vilar à plaisir pour cette finale deux
académies sont représentés versailles et
créteil sur les cinq équipes en lice
seules deux pourront se qualifier aux
championnats de france
on se bat on donne tout ce qu'on a sur
certains matchs et à quelques erreurs
vont après on est là pour s'améliorer
aussi l'association sportive de rugby
féminin a été créé il ya seulement
quelques mois ou lycée jean vilar
les joueuses s'entraînent une fois par
semaine cet événement permet notamment
de mettre en valeur ce sport qui se
développe de plus en plus chez les
femmes
mes filles vont moins vite c'est moins
impressionnant en termes de vitesse de
jeu par contre c'est un rugby où il ya
beaucoup plus de continuité le ballon à
la vie bien les filles arrivent à
vraiment mettre pas mal de pas mal de
rythme et de continuité dans le jeu donc
c'est un rugby qui est agréable à
regarder
c'est c'est en même temps aussi une
ambiance au sein de l'équipe qui est
vraiment chouette
on se soude on est vraiment on se parle
beaucoup et on se motive les uns les
autres et vraiment c'est ça qui nous
fait se motiver on sait que ni à nos
amis qui sont dans les gradins notre
famille des fois aussi des professeurs
des les surveillantes c'est important
pour elle c'est important pour
l'établissement à vivre une expérience
riche et j'espère que nous ferons que
nous font que débuter qu'on ira beaucoup
plus loin les années prochaines
les filles du lycée jean vilar termine
sur la deuxième marche du podium
l'île de france sera représentée par
deux lycées de l'académie de créteil au
championnat de france
il y avait du handball féminin ce
week-end montigny le bretonneux à signer
une large victoire ce week-end à
domicile contre dreux lésiné montaigne
se sont imposés 37 à 25 10 buts de leur
star ni naji reach
ce résultat leur permet à leur dixième
de la saison leur permet de remonter à
la deuxième place du classement
résultat de football américain les
templiers d'elancourt ont une nouvelle
fois écrasé leurs adversaires les élans
courtois se sont imposés 35 à 0 face aux
diables rouges de villepinte lors de la
5e journée de deuxième division
cette victoire leur permet de prendre la
première place de leur poule et
d'envisager une qualification pour les
playoffs de fin de saison
direction maintenant lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines pour parler
équitation une compétition le dressage
était organisée ce week-end 78 cavaliers
venus des quatre coins de l'île de
france et des départements voisins ont
participé à ce rendez vous les sportifs
devaient réaliser pendant leur passage
entre 19 et 20 figure imposée avec leur
cheval
karine piccinini responsable de sky
équitation nous présente les objectifs
des cavaliers sur cette compétition
soit c'est un travail personnel pour
leurs chevaux dans un terme de
progression
ça c'est la première chose et
deuxièmement peuvent s'ajouter des
qualifications futur pour les
championnats de france
ils sont en fait obligés de participer à
des compétitions et avoir un minimum de
résultats pour être qualifié au
championnat de france
on va maintenant ouvrir une large page
cyclisme on commence tout d'abord par
léa championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés la semaine dernière à berlin
l'équipe de france a remporté cinq
médailles dont une en or pour décrypter
ces résultats nous recevons sur ce
plateau jean michel richefort membres à
la fée est la ffc ainsi que laëtitia
beynat pistarde originaire de bullion et
qui tentera un record au vélodrome
nationale on en parlera un petit peu
plus tard
bonsoir
bonsoir alors bilan positif ou pas jean
michel richefort est bien bien en demi
teinte
on attendait un peu plus de nos sprinter
nous avons une très bonne équipe de
sprint et là je pense qu'ils sont un peu
passés à côté une quatrième place en
vitesse par équipes c'est décevant
l'équipe de france avait l'habitude
toujours d'être sur le podium 4e en
vitesse individuelle donc les résultats
ont été décevants notamment pour
sébastien billets et sur le kilomètre
bien quentin lafargue de perd son titre
de champion du monde deuxième au
kilomètre médaille d'argent bon c'est
une consolation médaille de bronze pour
michael d'almeida
alors après côté satisfactions au niveau
du rance bien sûr corentin ermenault
corentin hormonaux poursuiteur médaille
de bronze
et côté satisfaction aussi la jeune père
c'était le net et copponi caraco pony
qui est licencié au le cska il faut le
rappeler qu'ils ont terminé deuxièmes
american médaille d'argent et bien sûr
notre champion du monde pajama thomas
qui sauve un peu le bilan de l'équipe de
france aux championnats du monde
justement laetitia benjamin thomas on
voit à l'écran après sa belle victoire
il a 24 ans il a habité à trappes
quelques années c'est une magnifique
victoire
oui oui surtout que c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils et ramènent un
maillot de champion du monde quand même
après faut aussi souligner que quentin
et mathilde mon ami le constat lafargue
et mathilde euro ont quand même aussi
amélioré leurs temps donc c'est un peu
du positif quand même pour les
sprinteurs benjamin thomas c'est une
confirmation plus qu'une surprise
finance est une confirmation parce que
c'est un champion c'est un pisteur et on
peut compter sur lui dans les grands
rendez vous et il sera il sera présent
aux jeux olympiques maintenant les jeux
olympiques c'est dans cinq mois
donc on sait qu'on peut compter sur lui
et j'espère que nos sprinteurs vont se
ressaisir
chez les garçons et bien sûr mathilde
également qui est passé un peu au
travers de ces championnats du monde
maintenant il n'y a plus le choix ils
sont tous au pied du mur ils doivent
s'entraîner dur se met en mode commando
et préparer ces jeux cjo de la meilleure
façon possible
quentin lafargue a gagné du coup cette
médaille d'argent sur le kilomètre mais
cette épreuve n'est pas olympique
oui mais voilà il faut rappeler que le
qui fait partie du v6 sky vélo c'est
long pour 1 51 me mets donc il sera
malgré tout dans l'équipe de vitesse par
équipes
normalement ils sont quatrièmes à là ils
vont vraiment se concentrer vitesse par
équipes it s individuelle et kering bien
sûr il a aussi toutes ses chances de
disputer le quai ring mais voilà c'est
dommage que le kilomètre ne soient
pauvres aux jo mais c'est ainsi mathilde
de groulx la pépite française
l'annoncent comme tel depuis depuis
plusieurs années elle a été éliminée dès
les 8e de finale du tournoi de vitesse
individuelle et elle a été éliminée en
demi finale du keirin
est ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter laetitia
pour mathilde de gros j'espère que non
je pense pas à la vente en a 20 ans il
faut qu'elle apprenne et après c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas non plus beaucoup
beaucoup de courses pour pouvoir prendre
de la maturité sur les courses donc non
j'espère franchement qu'elle va
progresser sur le 200 m à la battu son
record donc un point positif
un point positif jean michel richefort
est ce qu'il faut c'est que je sais
c'est positif
elle progresse bien sûr elle est jeune
elle un fort potentiel potentiel pour
pour devenir médaillé olympique
championne du monde mais il faut qu'elle
apprenne encore faut qu'elle apprenne
faut qu'elles acquièrent de l'expérience
et ce qui lui manque aujourd'hui c'est
un peu d'expérience voilà tout
simplement
mais elle est très jeune et je crois
qu'elle arrivera au sommet de son art
pour les jeux olympiques 2024 à paris et
surtout sur le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dernière question est-ce qu'il faut tout
changer après ces championnats du monde
ou garder ses pistes harkis étaient
présents sur ces championnats du monde à
berlin à bien et l'équipe de france qui
était à berlin
c'est l'équipe de france qui sera qui
sera bien sûr aux jeux olympiques bien
sûr qu'il faille bouleversement non on
garde à vue le bouleversement je crois
que il ya vraiment un bon groupe mais il
faut être conscient que toutes les
nations à cinq mois des jeux olympiques
sont déjà un très haut niveau et
d'ailleurs nos pistard progresse nos
pistard battent leur record personnel
mais les autres nations sont préparés et
l'année des jeux olympiques
les niveaux de performances sont très
très élevé alors maintenant mais il
reste encore à travailler il reste cinq
mois cinq mois pour atteindre l'objectif
suprême
l'objectif suprême qui est d'aller
décrocher donc plusieurs médailles aux
jo et c'est ce qu'il faut leur souhaiter
on en parlait il ya quelques instants la
pistarde mathy de gros c'est justement
prêté à notre désormais incontournable
jeu des trois questions lors de notre
visite au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juste avant
les championnats du monde à remontage de
romain aarhus pini regardé et on réagit
à juste après
[Musique]
ça a été par hasard à la vache faisait
du basket est comme ça ça m'est tombé
dessus chez areva au vélo en fait je
faisais des tests sur un quad bike au
creps d'aix en provence en tant que
basketteur et j'ai fait des tests assez
impressionnant et arrivé jusqu'aux
oreilles de l'entraîneur de 10,6 mon
premier titre de championne d'europe à
glasgow
parce que ça a été mon premier titre
important chez les élites je pense que
enfin voila c'était une émotion
extraordinaire il y avait ma famille je
n'en revenais pas
les jeux bas après berlin on verra paris
2024 c'est encore très très loin mais
bien sûr on est très content que ce soit
ici
jean michel richefort une petite
réaction par rapport à cette séquence
ben oui est tout à apprendre un levier
du basket donc on a détecté son
potentiel
effectivement alors prêts potentiels
malheureusement en france n a pas
d'opposition donc c'est lui manque
également à l'entraînement mais elle a
vraiment la volonté de réussir
et puis il faut faire confiance à
l'encadrement l'encadrement de l'équipe
de france également aux entraîneurs
nationaux et je pense que bon voilà son
son réel objectif
bien sûr elle sera à tokyo à la le
potentiel pour aller chercher une
médaille mais elle arrivera à maturité
en 2024
ici chez nous à saint quentin on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cette page agenda du cyclisme
encore et toujours le paris-nice partira
des yvelines et plus précisément de
plaisir ce dimanche 8 mars le lendemain
le peloton s'élancera depuis chevreuse
pour nous parler de son rendez-vous nous
sommes toujours avec jean michel
richefort et lætitia abena que pensez
vous de ce paris-nice 2020 il de son
départ de plus plaisir laetitia et il ya
ces liens c'est pas loin de chez nous
non c'est une grande première pour la
commune
oui oui oui même pour chevreuse petite
pensée pour l'hôpital où je travaille
parce que c'est le grand chamboulement
village départ donc à chevreuse le
dimanche allez lens
mais non jean michel richefort ce départ
de plus plaisir qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
ben que du positif c'est la ville de
plaisir accueille ce paris nice avec une
très belle première étape une étape de
234 km 134 km en passant par les mines
hull en passant par gambe et touahri la
mairie de château voilà
neauphle-le-château deux fois avec la
côte de neauphle-le-château une cote de
1 km 400 à 7,8 pour cent et le deuxième
passage sera à cinq kilomètres de
l'arrivée
alors peut-être que des puncheurs pour
en sortir et pour éviter une arrivée au
sprint mais je pense que ce sera une
très très belle étape
et surtout ce qu'il faut souhaiter c
un temps clément pour que la fête soit
réussie
c'est une étape du coup pour les
puncheurs ça ne peut ni changer le type
de cours à son nom oui le dimanche puis
ce sera pour les puncheurs puncheurs ou
sprinteurs attention parce que bon les
deux premières étapes souvent les
sprinteurs s'illustrer et 10 militaires
comme kabélé one
sam bennett matteo trencin pascal
ackermann
là il ya vraiment les meilleurs
sprinters internationaux voilà mais
aussi des puncheurs comme benoît cosneau
froid qui est capable de de sortir dans
cette côte
de neauphle le vieux pour aller chercher
la victoire alors il y aura des têtes
d'affichés sur ce rendez vous notamment
julian alaphilippe on va l'écouter
justement juste pour vous dire que c'est
un bon moment et que je suis vraiment
très impatient de de revenir en europe
en france et spécialement à saint-amand
pour le contre la montre de paris nice
tu donc voilà j'ai vraiment vraiment
très impatient je m'entraîne dur et
j'espère que tu as plaisir la gueule et
qu'on passe un bon moment
jean michel richefort les meilleurs
poids du moment quasiment seront tous
présents sur ce paris-nice il est les
meilleurs avec les flics qui avait rêvé
nouveaux français sur ce tour de france
il revient au coeur le vainqueur sortant
égale verdun bernal qui sera là
vainqueur du tour et bien sûr thibaut
pinot
on aura également
la tour qui sera là mais queen tana un
quilt anna warren barguil qui sont très
en forme et l'a par contre julien
sur ce qu'il a montré hier sur la
classique drôme-ardèche je pense qu'il
est un peu en retard sur sa préparation
1 par rapport à l'an dernier est bon
c'est un puncheur c'est un champion il
est capable d'aller chercher mais il y
aura une grande concurrence et surtout
la 4e étape la quatrième étape chez lui
un certain moment rond c'est un
contre-la-montre individuel de 15 km
oula déjà les écarts vont s'affirmer les
meilleurs on se découvrir et les trois
dernières étapes ce sont des étapes de
moyenne montagne autour de nice qui font
la différence donc il y aura vraiment
super paris-nice encore cette année les
yvelines et le paris nice une histoire
qui dure depuis 2010 regarder cette
séquence
[Musique]
côté supporteurs ce prologue du paris
nice c'est la bonne occasion de revoir
les idoles de demander un autographe
michel par exemple suivi la carrière du
directeur sportif de l'équipe de la
française des jeux
marc madiot depuis 27 ans en suivant
tous les coureurs de la française des
jeux a bien contenu sur une course on
encourage toute l'équipe
six à neuf coureurs on applaudit des
neuf coureurs donc on équipés de
drapeaux supporters vêtements supporters
voilà on a la panoplie du parfait
supporter et même de petits nuls
l'ourson la voiture quand on est
passionné de cyclisme c'est assez
formidable ddt au contact de les voir
passer dans à côté de nous et tout c'est
dans ces tops chez moi je suis pas
comment dire mais bon c'est ça ça fait
quelque chose
côté coureurs l'ambiance est plus
concentré après une reconnaissance du
parcours le dimanche matin à la
mi-journée l'heure était aux
échauffements pour les premiers partants
du prologue ça c'est compliqué il ya une
bosse de départ qu'un petit secteur pavé
bon
les positions général quand même se joue
aussi un petit peu au début sur certains
paris nice il ya pas vraiment de les
gros leaders les dix premiers il n'y a
pas forcément de d'écart quand il ya des
arrivées au sommet donc c'est important
tout le monde cet état pire encore du
chemin fer donc bon c'est un maximum
aujourd'hui mais on verra aussi les
prochains jours il ya des choses à faire
c'est le néerlandais lars boom de
l'équipe rabobank qui a remporté ce
contre-la-montre de 8 km autour de
montfort l'amaury en dix minutes 56
secondes
[Musique]
une belle histoire ce paris nice dans
les yvelines une dernière question sur
le paris nice je suis obligé de vous la
poser est-ce que ce paris nice aura bien
lieu malgré les risques de couronnes un
virus oui pour l'instant il n'est pas
question d'annuler paris nice sauf si
l'épidémie se propage
bon là pour l'instant comme certaines
grandes rencontres là ce jour le paris
nice a lieu pas nouvelle pour l'instant
pas nouvelle mais les choses évoluent
rapidement
alors le paris-nice partira donc ce
dimanche depuis plaisir le peloton fera
une boucle en civil lundi prochain
départ depuis la commune de chevreuse à
12h25 on continue à parler de cyclisme
ce sera ce samedi les six heures au
vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de 13 heures à
19 heures juste avant laetitia abena
vous allez tenter un record de l'heure à
partir de 11 heures
est-ce qu'on vous nous présenter cet
événement oui donc je vais tenter de
battre le record de l'heure actuellement
qui est de 38,3 qui est détenu depuis
en effet j'étais c'est la fédération
sportive et gymnique du travail donc
j'appartiens au club de mareil sur maul
dans la fédération fsgt et aussi au club
de vélizy en ffc
donc je vais tenter de battre ce record
et puis j'ai ouvert une petite cagnotte
en ligne au profit de la face et
l'association françois aupetit c'est une
association pour les malades et les
familles des malades qui sont atteints
de la maladie de crohn et de la
rectocolite hémorragique
car je suis moi même atteinte de cette
maladie depuis cette donc j'ai voulu
montrer aux malades et puis aux familles
qu'on peut pratiquer du sport même du
sport intensif tout en suivant un
traitement assez lourd parce que vous le
présentez justement cette maladie c'est
une maladie inflammatoire des intestins
et c'est une maladie chronique dont on
ne guérit pas tout comme la maladie de
crohn donc c'est pas repoussé on peut ne
pas avoir poussé pendant plusieurs
années comme être vraiment handicapé au
niveau 1 un destin grosse fatigue que
j'ai eu l'hiver dernier tout le monde
peut en témoigner au vélodrome
donc voilà alors donc vous voulez
réaliser 38 3 km c'est bien ça alors je
voudrais battre ce record
je vise au minimum 40 de 142,5 au plus
gros d'entre eux justement alors c'est
j'ai la chance d'avoir un coach en or
c'est benjamin edelin qui ancien
cycliste de l'équipe de france ancien
sprinter du clip de france et donc il
m'entraîne depuis mois de juillet une
grosse préparation et bien sûr bas il
fait aussi en fonction de l'état de ma
fatigue liée à ma maladie à mon
traitement
une réaction jean michel richefort sur
ce set hâtive de records oui moi j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour tous les gens
qui se lancent ce genre de défi
un record en record de l'heure c'est un
gros investissement personnel
c'est un entraînement et pour avoir
assisté à plusieurs entraînements de
laëtitia moi je suis vraiment admiratif
parce que c'est de l'endurance mais à
chaque fois on repousse ses limites
je ne doute pas que laëtitia face cac 40
2,5 voire 43 moi je dirais plus 43 km
heure ce qui est remarquable et qui la
placerait juste derrière jeannie longo
qui avait fait 40 5 kilomètres c'est
situer la performance est franchement
ben je souhaite de tout coeur que samedi
à midi et bien laetitia atteignent 43 km
or voilà moi c'est
c'est le pari que je fais et je pense
qu'elle a ses 43 km heure dans les
jambes et elle va y arriver
alors il n'y aura pas que leur corps ce
syndrome il y aura donc les six heures
au vélodrome est ce que vous nous en
dire plus rapidement le programme géré
les six heures c'est la deuxième édition
de 6h alors six heures au vélodrome six
heures par équipe par équipe de 4 alors
équipes hommes et qui peuvent femmes
équipes mixtes donc nous aurons 24
équipes en piste et avec vraiment des
des assidus de la piste
deux jeunes champions yvelinois des
moins jeunes et également une tête
d'affiche en la présence de la personne
de morgan kneisky qui sera l' ancien
ancien champion du monde sur piste et il
nous fait l'honneur d'être présent et il
sera également le parrain de ces six
heures voilà alors ça va être la fête
l'après-midi sur le vélodrome six heures
6 heures de plaisir et 6 heures de
spectacle merci à vous d'être passé sur
ce plateau les six heures du vélodrome
c'est donc ce samedi à partir de 13
heures et n'oubliez pas leur corps de
laetitia un peu plus tôt ce sera aux
alentours de 11 heures il y aura
également un rendez vous insolite ce
week-end le département va accueillir
pour la première fois un ride and run le
principe un concurrent est à cheval et
l'autre à pied les participants doivent
alterner pendant la course l'événement
est organisé à partir de 10h au haras
des bréviaires plusieurs dizaines de
concurrents sont attendus pendant
l'événement on termine par cette
information l'ancien footballeur de
nantes et du paris saint-germain patrice
loko était jeudi dernier à fontenay le
fleury le sportif a rendu visite à lézat
cotera de la ville la structure est
constitué de 105 travailleurs handicapés
leur permet de se réinsérer socialement
patrice loko a également rencontré à
cette occasion deux encadrante qui vont
participer au rallye des gazelles du 14
au 28 mars on écoute patrice loko au
micro de tv 78
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup pour les
grandes causes effectivement souvent
pour des enfants parce que ça me tient à
coeur
et puis aujourd'hui c'est sur le
handicap psychique c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne parle pas beaucoup
au jour d'aujourd'hui on parle de
handicap moteur mais psychique pas de
trop et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup à
faire et surtout les aider dans ce
ce genre de choses et notamment au
niveau du travail c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
oui